after two endless days of battling
Flames from the ground and the sky the
wildfires ravaging the island of Maui
are now largely contained but what they
leave behind are scenes of a community
raised to the ground
the Beachside town of Lahaina once the
Royal capital of the Hawaiian Kingdom
and The Keeper of historic Treasures is
now unrecognizable evacuated residents
who took shelter at high schools and
parking lots fear what they'll find when
they return home woke up this morning
and got on our phone
house
just down to them
slap Nothing But Smoke
centers came with the clothes we got on
and a dog and two kids here we are
President Joe Biden approved a Hawaii
disaster Declaration on Thursday
desperately
they've lost a
anyone who's lost a loved one whose home
has been damaged or destroyed is going
to get help immediately if anybody's
still out here it's time to go the U.S
Coast Guard rescued 14 people who turned
to the ocean to escape the Flames now
members of the Hawaiian National Guard
and the U.S army combed through the
wreckage for survivors the primary focus
is to save lives
and to prevent human suffering and to
mitigate great property loss there's
also the loss to the tourism industry
Maui's main economic driver at least 11
000 tourists were evacuated this
evacuated couple from Canada says it
seems impossible to escape wildfires
wherever you are in the world
we were closer to them here than they
are we are in Canada for those a lot
there it smells like the air quality
similar the exact causes of Hawaii's
wildfires are still unclear but few
doubt the planet's warming climate was
an enabler
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera